at first glance the small town of Rula
in central lithuania doesn't look like
much of a target for an invading army
the local supermarket is the only thing
resembling a landmark but because Rula
is barely 100 kilometres from the
russian border many inhabitants feel
uneasy to secure this strategic location
NATO troops have moved into barracks at
the edge of town but construction isn't
finished yet not even the temporary
headquarters is complete we'll have a
battle group ready to deploy here we're
still in the development phase but we'll
be ready soon it will be part of a
Lithuanian Brigade that represents all
of NATO's efforts that's how we'll make
a substantial contribution to NATO's
deterrence capability 1000 NATO soldiers
should arrive by summer with tanks and
other heavy equipment German Dutch and
Belgian troops will be on hand to carry
out exercises with their lithuanian
hosts together with US troops already
stationed here the NATO soldiers want to
create a bulwark against any ambitions
of Russian expansion it's highly
improbable that Moscow will be impressed
by the NATO troops deployed here in
Brooklyn instead the Kremlin is most
likely going to respond with a military
buildup of its own sending more soldiers
to its western border for example or
more arms to its exclaim of Kaliningrad
it's a risk Germany and NATO are
deliberately willing to take to send the
message NATO stands as one and is ready
to defend Lithuania and its other
Eastern member states that's a signal
Lithuanians welcome but in Rula not
everyone feels the same way I'm afraid
there might be a war we need more
soldiers from other countries that will
make us feel safer they're all very nice
to us here it makes no difference
whether troops are stationed here or not
if Russia wants to invade us the first
missiles will hit us and destroy
everything actually pack without despite
NATO's presence the anxiety in Brooklyn
is palpable the fear of Lithuania cyant
neighbor and former occupier remains